Andrew Kincanno:
I think sports really teaches you how important
it is to work hard, to be successful.
It teaches you also how to develop friendships.
When you're involved in a sport with another
individual, you're practicing, and you're
hurting.
It's tough out there, and you're doing it
together.
Sports is a great experience in terms of just
developing and creating friendships; a way
of life, in terms of the way you work and
also how you get along with people.
Back in the '50s there were not that many
scholarships available; so, when I look at
what Hillsdale did for me ... The opportunity
to go to a college and play would be really
something great ... probably I was the only
guy in the neighborhood who was fortunate
enough to do that.
I've had a chance to coach with Muddy ... He's
had a lot of success ... and then Bill Mallory.
We won the conference championship and went
to the California Bowl that we won.
I think as a coach it's probably one of the
best things that you work for.
Not everybody is fortunate enough to go to
a bowl game; so, when you finally have a chance
to go and you're successful, it's a great
experience.
I can look back at some of my best friends,
playing and coaching now.
You go through so much.
You lose, and it's tough.
You win, and it's great.